The new game that will ruin your friendships is here.
Animal Party
you will be able to control one of these 28 nice
Look how beautiful and huggable they are!
A little
don't you really want to kick their fucking face in?
That's right!
At Party Animals
these huggable characters will cling to each other with a chingadazo
clean or with some chacos,
or with 1bar,
or with a frying pan,
or with a racket,
or whatever they encounter,
even with a trout kitty!
Share steps on one of the many maps in this game
with different themes
like American soccer,
Coqui,
a bridge over a river at the mouth of a crocodile,
a laboratory with a black fool and many,
many more.
yourself to madrazos
with your friends or strangers online
or share cock with the guy next to you
in its local multiplayer mode.
Get ready to prove that you are the most adorable.
among the children of the
of your friends,
because Party Animals
now available in the Steam store
and Xbox,
so prepare your best insults for